sans aucun culture
ce n'est pas un côté producteurs de
bovins depuis 25 ans sa ferme c'est
toute sa vie
pourtant au fil des années est devenu
une source d'anxiété qu'il ne peut plus
ignorer
je dirais qu'au mois de septembre il y
avait plus de sue j'ai craqué le moment
précis c'est le 9 2 septembre
ça s'est arrêté là je me suis mis à
pleurer
ça a duré deux semaines de temps le plus
motivé plus rien et puis voulaient plus
venir aux animaux j'avais juste envie de
me sauver
aujourd'hui le nombre d'heures parce que
c'est toujours une culpabilité
ça me rattraper le malaise le malaise
grandit l'eau jusqu'aux auteurs qui ont
capté la petite coquille intérieur
craquer cet automne le stress et
l'anxiété font partie du quotidien de
bien des agriculteurs 46 % d'entre eux
affirment avoir déjà ressenti de la
détresse psychologique et le taux de
suicide est deux fois plus élevé chez
les agriculteurs que dans la population
générale
comme quand l'hiver arrive c'est quand
tu dis je lis vers des fois que les
agriculteurs ça peut être des pensées
noires
c'est dans ce temps là des fois qu'ils
peuvent être plus à risque pendant ce
temps d'apprendre le plus possible
d'antennes ce territoire très capable de
capter ça ces antennes ce sont eux une
quinzaine de travailleurs de rang
déployés dans les milieux ruraux aux
quatre coins du québec
à l'image des travailleurs de rue ils
n'attendent pas que la clientèle
viennent à eux ils vont à sa rencontre
nous on fait des rondes à l'un des
relais c'est à dire qu'on passe par les
fermes puis qu'on va se présenter on
donne des cartons dit alors on est là on
existe et c'est comme ça que sandra a pu
tendre la main à stéphane lorsqu'il a
craqué on se parle d'être deux fois par
semaine là vraiment réussi à me remettre
les mots pour m'aider à voir à
visualiser qu'est ce que je ressentais
puis même
mme apaiser un peu dans tout ça un
producteur agricole c'est son mode de
vie c'est travail travail travail et il
n'y a pas le droit d'être blessé n'y a
pas de vote pour des vacances j'ai
palois de ville d'émotion mais là nous
on arrive c'est un regard tu as le droit
d'avoir dose de faire de ta vie ou
est-ce que tu m'as du taxi doivent
permettre de normaliser leur état est
c'est normal vous sentez comme ça
regardez tout ce que vous vivez les
facteurs de stress qui viennent avec la
production agricole
à l'heure où le québec compte sur ces
agriculteurs pour atteindre l'autonomie
alimentaire
le ministre de l'agriculture croit plus
que jamais en l'importance de prendre
soin de la façon d'en prendre soin
c'est de reconnaître à quel point ce
qu'ils font c'est essentiel une chose de
bon avec la pandémie il sait que les
consommateurs les consommatrices ont
peut-être ont une sensibilité accrue
aujourd'hui de l'importance de ces
gens-là ses fans lui a finalement pris
une décision qu'il ne pensait jamais
prendre se départir de son troupeau
il tourne la page le temps de retrouver
le calme il équilibre je peux mourir je
revis je dis vive au sens large c'est me
retrouver en plein come by la seule la
stratégie que j'ai trouvé cette prendre
producteurs agricoles va sacrer dehors
on va rétablir
l'homme s'est établi à l'homme à sa
place qui par la suite dont 20 euros sur
les capable de faire une place aux
professeurs et l'école qui est en moi
ici valérie gamache radio canada c'est
nazaire ou lac saint jean